Man, it’s even better on the fifteenth read...
Oh, hello!
I didn’t see you there, dear viewers of
SCP Explained.
I’m on break between supervising SCP-682
termination attempts and inspecting the mops
we use on SCP-173’s leavings, so I decided
to do what all the cool people are doing in
their spare time right now: Rereading Chainsaw
Man, the hit manga by Japanese author and
artist Tatsuki Fujimoto.
For the uninitiated, it’s the story of Denji,
a poor young man from Japan who makes his
living hunting devils - dangerous creatures
that are embodiments of mankind’s greatest
fears.
But when that living leads to him dying at
the hands of a gang of zombie yakuza - believe
me, it makes sense in context - he bonds with
the legendary Chainsaw devil and is reborn
as Chainsaw Man, an unconventional superhero
who chainsaws first and asks questions later.
Naturally, I was eager to see how one of our
own bloodthirsty killers would fare against
Denji’s chainsaws of fury, so I selected
the most violent, battle-hardened, and carnage-hungry
anomaly out there: SCP-076-2, the immortal
warrior known as Able.
The two of them have a surprising amount in
common.
Both are effectively immortal and can revive
after sustaining massive physical injuries.
Both absolutely love to fight with their array
of deadly weapons and anomalous strength.
Both have been part of experimental operations
groups - with Denji being a member of Japan’s
Public Safety Devil Hunter’s Division 4,
and Able being an ex-member of the SCP Foundation’s
disastrous Pandora’s Box Mobile Task Force,
most of which he later massacred out of boredom.
You can probably see why these two really
did feel like the perfect match-up.
So after forcing the trusty Anon-O-Tron 6000
to read every currently available volume of
Chainsaw Man, and compute years of Able’s
gruesome battle data, I’ve set up the perfect
simulation for your viewing pleasure.
And hey, fellow fans of the manga, isn’t
it horrifying that even we beat MAPPA to the
punch of animating this thing?
God, that joke will age poorly if that anime
comes out before this.
Anyway, let’s crank this machine into action
and let her rip!
Japan, 1997.
Everything is roasting in the July Heat.
Men In Black, Harrison Ford’s Air Force
One, and Air Bud are hitting theaters for
the first time.
Everything is right with the world.
That’s why, over in the headquarters of
the Public Safety Devil Hunting Department,
Denji - our Chainsaw-loving hero - is being
praised by his kind boss and mentor figure,
Makima.
A lovable, supportive woman who will never
do anything wrong.
She even loves dogs - how could a person who
loves dogs ever be evil?
That very morning, Denji, in his Chainsaw
Man form, managed to defeat the Accidentally
Making A Mistake On Your Tax Forms And Now
You’re Going To Prison Devil, who had been
terrorizing downtown Tokyo.
It was a challenging battle, but in the end,
he’d managed to turn the tables and defeat
the creature by setting it on fire.
Needless to say, Makima was extremely pleased
with Denji’s work here, but now, she had
considerable graver news to impart.
She’d gotten word from an envoy of another
organization that hunts down dangerous and
anomalous creatures - the SCP Foundation - that
an extremely lethal entity had breached their
containment and was now somewhere in Japan.
The entity in question was not a devil, and
thereby would be working on a different rule
set.
Makima opened a file faxed to her by the Foundation
- yes, remember, this is set in 1997 - and
gave Denji the crucial lowdown.
Several hours ago, the entity known as Able
had resurrected from his huge, black sarcophagus
in the underwater chamber of the classified
facility, Containment Area 25b.
After waking up, Able had slaughtered his
way through the entire base, killing every
SCP Foundation operative in his path and then
swimming out into the Pacific Ocean.
Sometime after that, he infiltrated a Japanese
cargo ship and murdered all the workers on
board, before steering the ship back towards
the land of the rising sun, where he hoped
to claim even more victims.
Makima told Denji that it would fall to him
and his associates to stop this Able, with
a little help from the SCP Foundation’s
intelligence.
But be warned: Able is an incredible combatant
with extreme physical strength and durability,
as well as surprising tactical intelligence.
It wouldn’t be an easy fight, but Makima
promised that if Denji won, she’d hug him
and go to a nearby karaoke bar with him.
Denji replied, “Consider him dead already,
Miss Makima.”
Meanwhile, Able was walking through the slums
of Tokyo, marveling at the neon signs for
bars and clubs.
His journey to Japan hadn’t been an accident.
Able had been to Japan once before, in the
year 1605.
He’d faced the legendary Japanese philosopher
and Swordsman Miyamoto Musashi, considered
by many to be one of the greatest warriors
in human history.
Able had dueled Musashi - who famously wielded
two Katanas at once - in the hills of the
Harima Province, where, after a tense battle,
Musashi cut him down.
Able would not resurrect again during Musashi’s
lifetime, but the battle gave him a deep and
abiding respect for the legendary warrior.
Able knew that if the opportunity ever rose
again, he would return to Japan, in hopes
of experiencing such a brilliant battle yet
again.
But the industrial and technological boom
had changed so much.
It was no longer the quiet and pastoral Japan
he’d experienced, but a booming epicenter
of trade and commerce.
He found it all strange and perplexing.
Suddenly, he found himself surrounded by a
group of Japanese street toughs, many of them
wielding switchblades.
They laughed at his strange outfit, which
to them looked like an old, worn bedsheet.
One of the smarter members of the group had
already decided to go home when the others
made up their mind to mug Able - the warrior’s
extensive tattoos made him look like a Middle-Eastern
yakuza don.
The rest, however, were happy to take their
chances with him.
“Empty your pockets, if that goofy toga
even has pockets,” the leader said, holding
up his switchblade.
“Unless you wanna get cut.”
Able just smirked and drew a pair of long,
obsidian daggers.
In the following moment, the alley was filled
with screams, then was silent yet again.
Able walked on, breathing a sigh of disappointment
at how incredibly mediocre this first fight
had been, his blades dripping with fresh blood.
Musashi is rolling in his grave, Able thought
to himself.
Meanwhile, across town, Denji and the rest
of Division 4 were mobilizing.
It was him, the serious, sword-wielding Aki,
and the adorable, pathologically-lying Blood
Fiend, Power.
They’d been told over the phone by a man
named Dr. Bright that Able would be relatively
easy to track down - He’s not known for
his subtlety; all you need to do is follow
the trail of carnage he causes wherever he
goes.
From the way he talks about him, it seems
almost as though Dr. Bright bears a personal
grudge against Able.
How strange.
Power didn’t seem intimidated.
She proudly proclaimed, “I don’t think
this battle will be difficult at all.
In fact, I’ve faced this Able before and
defeated him handily.”
Aki sighed and asked.
“When did this happen?”
“Last Tuesday, of course!”
she replied.
Power had only heard about Able this morning,
but Denji and Aki had learned better than
to dispute her at this point.
Suddenly, a large television screen that had
been previously relaying an ad for a cutting-edge
stereo system cut to an emergency news report.
There’d been a horrific incident in downtown
Tokyo, where a bar had been attacked and most
of its patrons murdered by a deranged, tattooed
man carrying a pair of huge swords.
Aki immediately recognized the place - The
bar was yakuza-owned.
If this Able was on the hunt for worthy opponents,
it makes all the sense in the world that Japan’s
iconic crime syndicates would be his first
target.
Denji, Aki, and Power knew exactly where they
needed to go.
Over at the bar, Able was having a whale of
a time.
Innocent patrons were running and screaming,
while the Yakuza engaged in an all-out war
with the terrifying, inhuman warrior.
Several of them had already been cut down.
Two Yakuza soldiers behind the bar were reloading
illegal Uzis and preparing to return fire.
Both were sweating, terrified by the sudden,
random attack.
When they’d shot him before, he’d managed
to dodge most of the bullets, and expertly
block the rest with his swords.
Who the hell had sent this monster?
Was he with the Triads?
The Russian mob?
Or some devil summoned by the Japanese government
to crack down on them?
Whatever the case, he seemed almost impossible
to kill.
The two men stood back up and opened fire.
Able held his two swords and spun them like
a propeller, blocking all the bullets almost
effortlessly.
He then produced another dagger, seemingly
from thin air, and threw it directly into
the heart of one of the two remaining Yakuza
behind the bar.
He dropped to the ground, dead instantly,
leaving only his friend alive in a bar full
of corpses.
That’s when Able noticed a decorative katana
behind the bar.
He smiled and ordered the surviving Yakuza
soldier to pick up the sword and give him
a real fight.
The hapless mobster realized in that moment
that this guy was truly crazy, whoever he
was.
But what choice did he have now?
With terror in his heart, the last surviving
Yakuza grabbed the katana and unsheathed it.
“Good,” Able said, his voice deep and
menacing.
“Now come fight me.
Let’s see if you last a few seconds longer
than your worthless friends, shall we?”
He did not.
The second the Yakuza ran towards Able, and
the ancient Swordsman swiped at him with one
of his blades, cutting through the katana
and then the opponent holding it.
A puny gangster never stood a chance against
a deadly immortal warrior, and Able was furious.
The last time he was here, he faced a truly
expert killer,
who’d even managed to end Able’s life
in single combat.
And now he was slaying insects in a karaoke
bar.
Pathetic…
Suddenly, his ears pricked up.
He turned to see a red axe flying at his head
at incredible speeds.
With his superhuman reflexes, he managed to
dodge just in time, but the axe still cleaved
off a chunk of his hair as it passed.
Able could see the one who threw it standing
at the entrance to the bar: It was the Blood
Fiend, Power, who’d made the axe out of
her own blood.
Standing next to her were Denji and Aki, Denji
wielding an axe and Aki stoically observing.
“Damn, Miss Makima promised we’d do karaoke
at this bar if I beat you,” Denji said.
“You’re going down for this.”
Able smiled and pulled out another pair of
blades.
“Finally!” he roared.
“Warriors who fight the old-fashioned way.
I feared the years had stolen you all from
me.”
Power stepped forward, producing another blood
axe from nowhere.
She yelled, “Tremble in fear, Able.
‘Tis I, your archnemesis, the mighty Power!”
Able had literally never seen her before in
his thousands of years of life, but he appreciated
that these warriors were at least able to
match his level of drama.
As far as he was concerned, the fight was
on.
But even Able didn’t know the level of fighting
he was getting in for here.
As he charged forward, the trio split, immediately
surrounding him.
Good tactics, Able thought to himself.
Already, this was promising.
Aki, who had remained quiet up to this point,
attacked first.
He drew a tanto knife from his suit jacket
and slashed at Able with impressive speed.
But unlike three of the other combatants in
this situation, Aki was only human, which
gave him a serious disadvantage.
Able decided it would be best to put him out
of commission first.
With a quick and brutal kick to the chest,
Aki was thrown against the wall with the majority
of his ribs broken.
Revved up by his own bloodlust, Able turned
to Denji and Power and grinned like a maniac.
This was already the most fun he’d had in
a long time.
Who are these people?
Doesn’t matter, he thought.
They’ll be dead soon anyway.
While Able was still locked in thought, Power
pulled out a comically large hammer made out
of her own blood, and brought it down towards
Able.
He was surprised by the sudden attack - Did
this girl have the same weapon-producing powers
as him!?
This just keeps getting more interesting!
“‘Tis the end, Able!”
Power screamed as the hammer came down.
“You have once again been defeated by the
mighty Power!”
Again, just to clarify, these two had never
met each other.
But it was already too late.
Able punched upwards, his clenched fist colliding
with the hammer.
He hit it with such terrifying force that
Power’s blood hammer shattered against his
knuckles.
In that same instant, Able noticed Denji running
at him with an axe from behind.
Able produced another obsidian dagger and
threw it into Denji’s forehead, dropping
him to the ground immediately.
Pathetic.
Power tried to produce another weapon, but
she’d used up too much blood already.
Before she had a chance to make anything substantial,
Able sprung forwards with terrifying speed,
trying to land a killing blow.
But even weakened, Power was freakishly fast.
She was able to dodge his blow and kick him
in the ribs, momentarily stunning him.
Of course, she took the time to gloat, putting
her hands on her hips and laughing victoriously.
“Need a second to catch your breath, Able?
It is to be expected.
None can keep up with me!”
She grandiosely announced.
“Perhaps you should just give up and agree
to become my servant.
I might even teach you a thing or two about
fighting—“
Suddenly, Able was standing right in front
of her, squeezing her throat with his iron
grip.
He smiled, flashing teeth, and said, “If
you want to kill, kill.
Don’t talk.”
With a surprisingly minimal amount of strength,
he squeezed and heard a crunch from Power’s
neck.
He dropped her limp body to the ground.
Lucky for Power, Able wasn’t aware that
a Fiend like Power can survive an injury like
this as long as she’s fed some more blood.
Instead, he just sighed in disappointment.
“Is that all you weaklings have to offer?”
He bellowed.
Aki, barely conscious after being kicked against
the wall, remained just conscious enough to
activate his contract with a powerful beast
known as the Fox Devil.
He twists his hands into a strange gesture
and whispers the word, “Kon”, before falling
unconscious.
But that’s still enough.
Suddenly, a giant demonic fox claw burst through
the wall of the bar, spraying dust and rubble
everywhere.
Able was definitely not expecting that.
He dodged several times as the claw swiped
for him, often barely missing him.
For its last strike, it lunged forward and
raked four claw marks across his chest.
Able was shocked by the sudden pain.
It felt fantastic.
He pulled a long, obsidian spear out of one
of his pocket dimensions, and forced it down
through the Fox Devil’s paw and into the
ground, pinning it in place.
After a moment of thrashing, the claw dissipated
into smoke, lending Able another victory - though
even he would admit this was a more exciting
fight than the other ones had been.
Was that it?
Had he gained total victory once more, just
like he so often did these days?
He was about to take pity on himself when
Denji rose up behind him.
“How about a rematch?”
Denji asked.
Able grinned.
He liked this kid.
“Challenge me, child,” Able said.
“Well, since you asked...”
Denji smirked.
Denji reached into his shirt and grabbed the
rip cord emerging from his chest.
It was time to go into overdrive on this thing.
He gave it a mighty yank, and like the rev
of a chainsaw, the madness began.
Denji transformed - Giant blades emerging
from his arms, and his head transforming into
a toothy, saw-blade nightmare.
He gave a mechanical roar that spewed smoke.
This wasn’t just Denji anymore.
This was Chainsaw Man.
Now this, Able thought, feeling his adrenaline
spike, is more like it!
Following Denji’s lead, Able reached into
one of his pocket dimensions and pulled out
one of his favorite weapons - one he’d only
previously used against the mighty Hard to
Destroy Reptile, SCP-682: The Chainsaw Claymore,
a huge, two-handed sword with the eternally
twisting, shredding teeth of a chainsaw ever
circulating around it.
It was time for Chainsaw Vs Chainsaw.
“What the hell are you waiting for?”
Chainsaw Man roared.
“Are we gonna stand around all day, or are
we gonna fight?”
Able couldn’t have said it better himself.
The two charged at one another at lightning
speeds, chainsaw clashing against chainsword.
The sheer force of contact was enough to send
a shockwave blasting through the bar.
It rapidly became a power struggle, each one
of them trying hard to force their chainsaws
out of the stalemate.
Realizing that this time he perhaps couldn’t
win with raw strength, Able backflipped away
to reassess his options.
But Chainsaw Man had no intention of giving
Able time to think about it.
He darted towards Able with the weight and
momentum of a runaway freight train.
If Able hadn’t raised his claymore to parry,
he would have been shredded to pieces by the
devil’s saws in an instant.
Instead, the two of them rocketed out of the
nearby wall in a cascade of debris, causing
everyone on the outside street to run for
their lives.
The two quickly stood from the stumble, catching
their breath.
“Impressive,” Able said.
“You’re much better than the others.”
Instead of replying, Denji briefly retracted
his arm chainsaws and grabbed a nearby parked
car, throwing it directly at Able.
Able reacted quickly, cleaving the car in
half with his claymore and charging for Chainsaw
Man again.
Just before Able could land a lethal strike,
Chainsaw Man deployed his chainsaws again,
blocking the blow.
Able sped around him, trying to strike again
and again, but Chainsaw Man blocked every
strike with stunning efficacy.
Able was astonished - few had ever been able
to go toe to toe with him like this before.
He could feel his heart pounding gloriously
in his chest.
He would give Denji a warrior’s death.
With a furious yell, Able brought down the
Chainsaw Claymore for a devastating vertical
strike, but Chainsaw Man was ready.
He arranged his arm chainsaws in a cross formation,
like a giant pair of scissors, and caught
Able’s chainsword between them.
Chainsaw Man pulled his arms in opposite directions,
slicing Able’s mighty sword in half.
The immortal Swordsman skidded backwards to
avoid the fallout, producing two smaller blades
immediately.
This Chainsaw Man just kept exceeding expectations,
didn’t he?
Able would need to change tactics if he wanted
to win this one...
Chainsaw Man was impressed by the speed and
tenacity of his foe.
For someone who apparently wasn’t even a
devil, Able sure packed a hell of a punch.
Did he ever run out of those damn weapons?
As though attempting to answer Chainsaw Man’s
question for him, Able began running around
his flank, rapidly producing and throwing
blades and axes in a startling volley.
Chainsaw Man was able to use his Chainsaw
arms and face to block most of them, but not
all of them.
Several daggers and small throwing axes splattered
into the tender flesh of Chainsaw Man’s
chest.
Able had successfully wounded him, and he
wasn’t done.
Feeling a little more confident now, Able
decided to take a different tactic: He produced
a large, spiked mace from thin air, and ran
at Chainsaw Man while the devil was still
recovering from his projectile attack.
With one brutal whack, he sent Denji flying
down the street, carving a rut into the concrete
beneath him.
But Able wasn’t done.
While Chainsaw Man was still trying to recover,
Able leaped onto him and began beating him
into the ground with his mace.
The strikes were so brutal they shook the
earth and sent cracks across the surrounding
ground.
Then Able stopped.
He realized, for a moment, that he was letting
his blood lust get the better of him.
This was dishonorable.
Where would be the fun in beating this boy
to death while he lay on the ground, and depriving
himself of one of the greatest opponents he’s
had in quite some time?
No, that wouldn’t do at all.
He’d give him one more chance.
“On your feet, boy,” Able said.
“You fight well.
Get up and carry on.
I won’t let a beast as rare as you die like
a common dog.
Rise and fight me!”
And Chainsaw Man did as he was told.
Able was shocked to see the very ground shatter
underneath him as Chainsaw Man burst up through
it, all his swords at the ready.
The mace was thrown from Able’s hands as
Chainsaw Man launched up towards him, all
metal teeth and fury.
Luckily for Able, he pulled out a battle axe
just in time to block the flurry of brutal
strikes from the patron saint of chainsaws.
Now this was a fight even Musashi would be
proud of.
“Yes, boy, yes!”
Able yelled.
“This is true combat!”
Chainsaw Man replied with the swing of his
blades, which Able was narrowly able to dodge.
The two finally landed back down on the ground,
and Able was fast enough to bury his battle
axe in Chainsaw Man’s shoulder.
Before the devil could return a blow to Able,
the anomalous Swordsman pulled out a pair
of his favorite swords and locked Chainsaw
Man’s arms in place.
Chainsaw Man was undeniably incredibly powerful,
but it looked like Able’s superior experience
and tactics might save him this time.
“What the hell are you?”
Chainsaw Man roared.
“You’ve been a worthy opponent, boy, those
are few and far between,” Able said.
“I’ll remember you for this...”
But before Able could execute a killing blow,
he felt a blood red throwing axe stick into
his back.
Able winced in pain and turned to see Power
and Aki about thirty feet behind him.
Power was propping Aki up - he’d donated
some of his blood to bring her back to life.
And she was just as delusionally cocky as
ever.
“Tis I once again, my arch-nemesis!”
Power yelled.
“Did you really believe you could beat me
so easily?”
Able was about to say something, but he’d
already made a fatal mistake: Letting his
guard down.
Before another word could pass the cursed
warrior’s lips, one of Chainsaw Man’s
arm chainsaws passed directly through his
heart, tearing it apart within Able’s chest.
It was a sudden and decisive killing blow.
Chainsaw Man pulled his saw back out of Able’s
chest, stained with the deadly anomaly’s
blood.
Able collapsed to the ground, wheezing and
bleeding profusely from the hole in his chest.
But strangely, as Power, Aki, and Chainsaw
Man converged around him, they realized he
was smiling.
“Thank you...”
Able said, and died yet again.
With the battle won, like an extremely metal
Incredible Hulk, Chainsaw Man transformed
back into Denji.
The trio stood around Able’s corpse, deeply
confused as to what had just happened.
If this was the kind of thing the SCP Foundation
normally dealt with, they all silently agreed
that perhaps it would be better not to get
involved with them in future.
Except Power, of course, who said, “You
two should be thanking me for defeating him.
You both owe me drinks for this!”
Hundreds of miles away, in a black sarcophagus
deep underwater, surrounded by professional
SCP Foundation divers, Able’s body once
again returned.
Who knows how long he’d remain sleeping
in there?
But what we do know is that his deathless
sleep was suffused with sweet dreams, knowing
that this world still held worthy opponents.
And for Able, that was everything.
Now go check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained
in the Backrooms?”
and “SCP-096 VS Siren Head” for more deranged
out-of-universe crossovers from the SCP Foundation!